good morning believe nation today's
message is take chances you look at the
world around you is the other great
successes the large companies of this
world and there are many and many
successful companies or are they the
companies that took chances where
individuals started in garages where
ideas were born where did Microsoft
wedded Apple waited amazon where did
google where did facebook come from they
came from ideas that people felt
something could be done and that they
could make a difference I believe that
it's better to take your shot and miss
than to never try at all and that
doesn't mean that you have to go all in
and mortgage your house and take on huge
debt to try to chase a big dream but it
also means that I don't want you to play
super safe and be so afraid to do
something that you never actually try
anything all of the big things that have
happened in my business and in my life
have come as a result of taking a chance
on something taking a chance on somebody
taking a chance in an idea and if it
doesn't work out at least I know that I
don't have to live the rest of my life
in regret wondering what if what might
have happened so be bold today pick a
chance and see what happens belief so my
question the day for you guys today is I
want to know a chance that you took that
you're proud of what's a chance that you
were scared up and you went for it
anyway that now you're so happy that you
went for it leaving the comments below
I'm curious to find out what you have to
say I think it will help inspire other
people as well thank you guys so much
for watching have an amazing day compete
to believe and i'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot a
vinspresso
expresso keep me going I work with more
this race OCD I wake up every morning